what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the kindest boy in anime
the one and only
tangelo commodore from demon slayer AKA
komatsuna Yaiba demon slayer is full of
awesome and extremely likable characters
I mean the Senate zoo in Oceania Zuko
and of course tan Jiro are all
compelling characters especially in
their interactions with each other but
the strength of demon slayer is that on
top of having characters with
personality and likability it also has
characters with really cool and complex
powers and abilities thanh 0 is
definitely a character with both an
extremely likeable personality and some
badass powers in this video I will be
explaining all of tangelos unique
abilities and powers including the
hidden power and potential that Tanja
too appears to have inherited through
his family line trust me there is a lot
to talk about when it comes to Tanja
rose power so let's get into it if you
enjoy the Demon Slayer content on this
channel and you'd like to see more
please leave a like to let me know and
if you're new to animal Probe forget to
subscribe and hit that notification
valve feel free to follow me on Twitter
and Instagram Pat anime uproar for all
the latest demon slayer news and updates
and finally this video will contain
manga spoilers about tangi rose powers
and also Nezha ghost powers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned when we first meet tangelo he is
a kind-hearted and hard-working young
man who cares deeply about his family
after the death of his father tan drew
row from illness
tangelo had to step it up and work hard
in order to help his family make ends
meet and in fact he is in charge of
traveling great distances to sell
firewood in order to earn enough money
for the family to survive but one
morning after he returns to his family's
mountain home tonzura finds that his
entire family has been killed by a demon
or rather his entire family except his
sister Nezu KO who has been turned into
a demon herself but when the water
hashira gu shows up to kill Nezha KO
because killing demons is what demon
Slayers do Tanja refuses to let the
demon slayer kill his sister
during the brief battle between tan
jianci you Natsu ko actually regained
some of her humanity and she puts
herself in danger in order to protect
her brother
because new Zuko's behavior is so
unusual and so different from the
behavior of ordinary demons GU decides
to do something that is unheard of among
the demon Slayers GU spares nazca's life
and he sends both nesco and tan zero to
his mentor and former water hashida
Sakon ji Oroku ducky loco ducky then
proceeds to train town zero for two
years in order to turn him into a demon
slayer now tan Jiro is determined to
become a Demon Slayer because he wants
to defeat Mouzon the demon final boss
who killed his family and he wants to
find a way to turn a Zuko back into a
human during his training with Roku
ducky he learns to use the breath of
water battle style the same
swordsmanship style that Gil uses I
won't get into all the specific moves
and forms that ton zero is capable of
performing using this style but if
you're interested about the specifics of
every known breath style feel free to
check out my video on every battle style
in demon slayer link in the description
in that video
I went all in on everything we know so
far about every single breath style to
be brief though when someone uses a
breath style they are essentially
controlling their breathing in a very
specific and deliberate way in order to
increase the amount of oxygen flowing in
their blood after mastering a breath
style the user is able to increase his
or her powers speed and agility to the
point that they can actually rival
demons in battle in general a demon is
much stronger than an ordinary human so
being able to fight on par with a demon
is already a massive accomplishment
after eventually learning to use full
focused breaths all the time including
when he is sleeping tan judo is able to
increase his speed strength and stamina
even further but this is not where the
full extent of ton zeros unique powers
and abilities ends at this point I want
to mention that tangier possesses an
incredibly sensitive sense of smell and
this heightened sense of smell is not
related to his Demon Slayer training he
possessed it even before he became a
Demon Slayer ton zero sense of smell can
often be a big advantage in battle
because it allows him to locate hidden
opponents smell the emotions and
therefore the intentions of other people
and even predict the movements of others
to some extent by using his sense of
smell as a guide
it also turns out that Tonto is able to
use a second breath style known as the
dance of the fire-god this is a breath
style known and taught only by the comet
of family and it is passed down from
father to son within the comet of
bloodline
interestingly enough the breath of
flames user Shinjiro Ren Goku claims
that the dance of the fire-god style is
actually the original breath the godly
breath that was the first ever created
and the one from which every other
breath is derived and the name of this
mythical style is the breath of the son
ginger Doran Goku considers all of the
other styles to be inferior copies of
the breath of the Sun we know that
tangelos family has a direct connection
to the original breath of the Sun user
so it is quite likely that the breath of
the Sun style or some form of it was
secretly passed down through town zeros
family under the guise of the dance of
the fire-god the dancer the fire-god
style has so far been used by tan Jiro
and by his father tandro who used the
dance of the fire-god style for a ritual
ceremony once a year as tan Jiro
continues to train and as he gains
greater mastery of the breath of water
and dancer the fire-god he unlocks new
abilities including the so called the
mark of the Sun state this state allows
Tantra to become even stronger and
faster and he is able to effectively
fight against upper moon demons in this
state although we have to mention that
while being in this state drastically
increases tangelos abilities he is only
rarely able to enter this state and he
is only able to use it for a small
amount of time before it takes a
tremendous toll on his body on top of
that tangelo is able to unlock even
higher potential when he combines his
abilities with the abilities of his
sister nez Zuko as we eventually find
out
Naza ko is able to use her blood to set
kanjuro sword on fire and turn it from
black to red when it becomes red tundra
sword looks like the red sword used by
the legendary breath of the Sun user who
lived many centuries ago as I mentioned
earlier there are multiple blatant clues
that tan Jo's family is directly
connected to the breath of the Sun user
including the hanafuda
earrings with the Sun symbol which were
said to have been worn by the breath of
the Sun user the dance of the fire-god
and marks entendre rose face which are
set to appear on warriors who use the
wrath of the Sun and so on it is worth
noting that in chapters 57 and 58 of the
manga we learned that tan Jiro has an
unusually warm bright and powerful
spiritual core which may become
important again at some point in the
future with such an above-average
spiritual core it is fair to assume that
tan 0 has above-average potential to
keep getting spiritually stronger more
so than an average person and even
though it may appear as if tan 0 is just
lucky because he was born with a family
connection to the breadth of the Sun he
has an unusually sensitive sense of
smell an unusually powerful spiritual
core and so on it must be emphasized
that even though he is a shown and
protagonist tanjo is not overpowered to
the point of being a broken character in
demon slayer powerful antagonists like
the upper demon moons are never defeated
by just pan Jiro and his lower ranked
friends alone because of how strong
their friendship is or because of how
badly they really want to win whenever a
major antagonist like an upper moon is
defeated in the series it is always due
to a lot of teamwork and it always
involves at least one hashira or pillar
sometimes it involves a whole group of
hashira fighting against the villain at
the same time along with some lower rank
demon Slayers like town zeros and itsu
and so on teamwork is extremely
important in demon slayer just getting
really angry at your opponent is not
going to secure your victory in this
series furthermore tandro is not the
only character with a direct connection
to the breadth of the Sun user for
example Mui cheeto the mist hashira also
has a direct blood connection to the
breath of the Sun user
so while tan Jiro was definitely born
with certain privileges pertaining to
his family lineage he is not entirely
unique in this regard after chapter 151
tan Jiro is able to unlock another
important battle technique he learns to
access the see-through world a world in
which all movements seemed slower and
within which tandro is able to see the
inside of his opponent's bodies and all
of his opponent's movements including
the movement of the opponent's lungs and
inner organs and this allows him to
predict an opponent's moves in battle
more accurately Tangiers dad was also
able to use this technique and upper
demon moon one Kaku Shiva can use it as
well
furthermore all humans have a battle
spirit that can be sensed by others but
in chapters 1 5 2 & 1 5 3 Tangier learns
to make his battle spirit and murderous
intent / hatred disappear completely
which prevents those who can sense
battle spirit and murderous intent from
sensing tangi Rose moves in battle so we
know that tan Jiro clearly has a lot of
special powers and abilities and at
least by the standards of a demon slayer
who is not a hashira tandro is pretty
overpowered considering his age the
amount of time he spent training and all
the feats that he was able to accomplish
against the upper moons tandro is indeed
quite opie relatively speaking but this
is nothing new for a shounen protagonist
and we've seen it many times over from
Austen Deku to meliodas and Goku to name
just a few
having an Opie main character is not a
problem as long as the rivals he faces
are also Opie and he doesn't just defeat
every rival on his own just because he
believes in the power of friendship even
though power creep is always a potential
issue in battle Shonen I think that at
least for now
demon slayer has handled Hondros power
pretty well yes he has a lot of special
powers and abilities and yes he was born
with unique advantages that others do
not have but tan Jiro is not the only
one with an especially powerful lineage
and he is not the only one who is
blessed with unique powers and abilities
moreover all the major fights against
the upper moons relied heavily on
teamwork and each time an upper moon was
successfully defeated one or more
hashira were involved in the fight on
top of the less experienced fighters
like Don zero Zenit zoo and inosuke even
though he is the protagonist tandro is
not out there defeating upper moons on
his own he is relying on teamwork
strategy and the help of the much more
experienced and skilled hashira my
prediction is that unless the manga ends
really soon which I don't think is going
to happen Tangier will continue to get
stronger but he will do so as part of a
team working along with Zenit soo
inosuke and Ned Zuko initially we
thought that as soon as a Demon Slayer
manifests the mark of the Sun on their
body they will die before the age of 25
however we recently learned in the manga
that the original breath of the Sun user
was able to live until the ripe old age
of 80
even after manifesting the mark
in his youth this shocked even kakushi
bow when he first found out about it
this tells me that Tangier on friends
will find a way to live longer just like
the original breath of the Sun user did
if it is possible and we now know it is
then Tangier Oh we'll find a way and I
believe the fact that on zero sword
turns red only with Nezzer close health
is symbolic of the fact that tandro
inuzuka
but also then it's soo and it knows ok
we'll have to work together as a team as
a right now none of them are experienced
or strong enough to defeat the upper
moons on their own and that goes double
for Moosa as overpowered as some of them
may appear to be compared to regular
lower rank demon Slayers they are not so
overpowered that they can just destroy
every villain on their own so there is
still a lot more room for growth in
addition we've already seen instances of
Tangier onizuka's then it's one inosuke
combining their unique techniques and
creating awesome combo attacks so I
expect to see more of that in the future
my main point is this I believe that
Tangier onizuka's mysterious lineage
will be crucial in the long term just
like nez Zuko was able to conquer the
Sun Tan Jiro will eventually learn to
conquer the curse of the mark of the Sun
and he will find a way to live a long
life just like the breath of the Sun
user did and I also believe that Tangier
oh and Nezzer Co secret connection to
the breath of the Sun will allow them to
find a way to save the other demon
Slayers who have begun manifesting the
mark of the Sun but that is just my
personal opinion obviously we can't know
for sure at this point and by all means
let me know what you guys think
how will Tangier on the others overcome
the curse of the Mark of the Sun and how
will they ultimately defeat Musa will
they all have to work together to do it
as I am inclined to believe or do you
think that one of the main characters
will emerge as the absolute strongest
let me know down in the comments if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more please leave a like to let me know
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell it's very
important if you want to see our videos
in the future feel free to follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at anime up lore
for all the latest demon slayer news and
updates i want to give a big thank you
to all of our anime upper patrons for
supporting our work and making our
videos possible
a special thank you to all of our pro
hero to your patrons including the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson King zelgius and on he'll
cruise on Epic thank you to all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all other clans including baby ray
ace
Ingrid ah Aloha Adam Maddy Mac
makoto-kun and Keylong and finally at
the pinnacle of interdimensional
greatness a tier reserved only for
legends a massive thank you to Regan
Harrison and Lord Noxon or disciples of
Lord we go himself if you enjoy our
videos and you think they provide value
for you consider supporting us on
patreon link in the description even a
single dollar will give you access to
our exclusive patron only discord and
your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]